hey guys it's sunup there was another
mass shooting in the United States this
week on the heels of the one-year
anniversary of the Orlando pulse
nightclub shooting this time it was in
Vegas but every time there's a mass
shooting especially where the numbers
are just so high there's always one
conversation topic that grips the
country gun control so while we're
working on an in-depth exploration of
the history of gun control and the
weapons industry we wanted to share some
of our existing content on gun violence
in the United States because check it
here at aj+ it's important for us to be
a resource for you not just tell you
what's happening in the world but really
understand it beyond the usual talking
points for instance we've got two pieces
that look at how gun violence in the
United States compares to gun violence
around the world there are 90 guns per
hundred Americans giving the country the
honor of the highest gun ownership rate
in the world in Canada you must register
your semi automatics and handguns with a
government in the US there are more
states that prohibit all gun
registration than states that have a
form of gun registration we've also got
a series exploring gun violence in the
United States including looking at the
popularity of the ar-15 assault weapons
and large capacity magazines were banned
for a decade during the ban the number
of people killed and wounded with
assault weapons or guns using
high-capacity magazines was cut in half
after the ban expired casualties shot up
by more than 300% and exploring how the
election of President Donald Trump has
impacted and will impact the gun
industry most all the people who hate
Trump or pussies take to the streets
with guns we've got the guns we've asked
what the history of gun control the
United States has looked like before the
Civil War the right to own guns it came
with the right to own black slaves after
the Civil War black Americans were
finally able to own guns which made many
white Americans fear and armed rebellion
and we've also looked at what are some
commonalities between some of the most
notorious mass shooters and it's not
just gender most mass shooters have in
common
another overlooked threat is a history
of domestic violence we've still got a
lot of work to do when it comes to
covering gun violence on the gun control
conversation
this country and we're working on
building that coverage next Sunday we'll
be publishing a longer in-depth piece on
the guns industry but let us know in the
comments what you want us to cover
what's overlooked and what we at aj+ can
do better
[Music]